but you can't mess up the one and only
Gayle King she is in Washington about to
talk with House Speaker Paul Ryan
looking forward to that his decision not
to seek reelection is sending
Republicans scrambling ahead of
November's midterm ballot speaker Ryan
joins a wave of Republicans who are not
running again this fall he is one of at
least 24 GOP House members who are
retiring Ryan says he is stepping bound
down to spend more time with his family
he said he's tired of being a quote
weekend dad Gail King is with speaker
Ryan in his office Gail good morning
again yes that's right John weekend dad
no more speaker Ryan is joining us now
to tell us tell us take us behind the
scenes of your decision because this is
the thing mr. speaker a couple of months
ago you said when you were asked about
it that's ridiculous I'm not even
considering it no way I'm here to stay
what has changed in the last couple of
what I said then well I wasn't gonna
resign and I'm not doing that
so the question was was I once tax
reform was done gonna resign and the
answer was no I'm gonna run through the
tape finish the term but I'd been
thinking I think the question implied
that you're going to be here for the
long haul well resign or retire but I
wasn't going to resign and I never ruled
our retirement I've said all along just
like Jenna and I do every two years we
before the filing deadline decide
whether we're gonna stay or not the
final deadlines coming up we made our
decision a different way this year you
know why because our kids aren't getting
younger I gotta tell you Gail I've had
so many people in their 50s 60s and 70s
tell me I wish I spent more time with my
kids well my kids have only known me
their entire lives is a weekend dad and
now they're teenagers in or about to be
in high school and did you ever consider
moving your family to DC so you wouldn't
happen yeah we thought about it but
we're Wisconsin heights you know we
thought about that but it's just didn't
seem to make sense to me I live on the
block I grew up on there are 10 Ryan
family households within 8 blocks of my
house I I'm I'm a big Janesville
Wisconsin guy I was I think I think mr.
speaker nobody questions your dedication
to your family and your love for your
family but I was taking the Acela
yesterday the four o'clock you were the
topic of conversation on the train and
people said this is I heard two schools
of thought you
freedom for him or what happened to Paul
Ryan did Trump fatigue in any way play a
role no the other factor is I feel like
I've actually gotten most done what I
wanted to do so I've been here 20 years
in Congress
the first issue I focused on they have
even video of me as a congressman elect
tax reform I was an old Jack Kemp guy
I've been working on tax reform since I
got here it's why I became chair of Ways
and Means Committee we got that done I'm
a big believer in a strong military our
military has been hollowed out it's been
it's been under duress
we are now fixing that that is done the
economic growth platform that we want is
in place the enterprise zones that I
used to work on for years is now in law
which helps poor communities revitalize
so the point being I have accomplished
most of what I came here to do the one
thing that still has to get down his
entitlement reform I'm proud that ever
since I was budget share the house has
passed budgets every every term to
balance the budget pay off the debt in
the House passed the biggest entitlement
reform bill ever considered last year
unfortunately it failed by a vote in the
Senate but the point being it's
basically two reasons
okay comments most about what I want to
accomplish and my like I said I don't
want to be a weekend dad for my kids
entire law okay so so you're very happy
with your decision but still I go back
to many people who say if we had a
different president in the White House
he would still be there and after a
while it just got to the point you know
this is what people said to me mr.
speaker what happened to Paul Ryan you
know why didn't he speak up
why didn't he stand up to the president
about things that many believe are
personally offensive to you and that if
we had a different person in the White
House that you would not be leaving no
that's not the case it's really a timing
of family and it's a fact that I've
accomplished much of the agenda I came
here to accomplish with the respect of
the president look I always act in a way
that I think is in the best interest of
the country to move us forward and I've
always found especially with my
relationship with the president we have
a very good very candid dialogue and I
find it's better to talk to the
president instead of talk about the
president on the on the TV on media so I
find that I have a much more effective
relationship with him by having personal
dialogues with him and going out and
wailing on them on TV that may score
points and may make people happy but I
don't see how it gets things done
so more importantly we have advanced a
very impressive agenda we
an agenda in 2016 we won the election
and we've been executing it ever since
and I'm very proud of that fact so I'm
very proud of the accomplishments but it
really is a phase of life if if if my
mentor jack kemp was still around and
was president today I'd still be going
home just not be a weekend yeah your
mentor Jack Kemp is very different from
President Trump do you ever feel that
you had to compromise your own personal
values to play along to get along no I
mean obviously we've had our differences
and we have disagreed privately and
publicly and that is the way it is but I
really do believe that that I've been
doing things that are in vestiges of the
country to move it forward like I said I
think having a candid dialogue it no
actually hasn't didn't make it difficult
for me he he gave us the ability to get
historic things in law that we've been
trying to get for a generation that's
not making things difficult that's
actually facilitating real reform that
by the way the economy's growing now
wages are going up people are getting
bonuses people are getting back to work
we are now on the cusp of pulling more
people out of poverty into the workforce
because he won the election and gave us
the ability to get these great policies
into place so you you had dinner with
the president last night there was a big
picture photo picture with the thumbs up
very celebratory what were you all
celebrating just the accomplishments
we've had two heretofore and then the
rest of the agenda that we're working on
we're working on infrastructure we're
working on some healthcare bills we're
working on lots of different bills with
respect to workforce development Career
and Technical Education and we were
celebrating the agenda we've passed and
the agenda we have yet to pass this this
this session in this spring because you
know when I look at that picture Mr
Speaker I have to say I don't see
anybody that looks like me in terms of
color or gender and you were one of the
main people that said you want to do
more for the Republican Party to expand
you wanted to expand the base
some say this president really doesn't
want to expand the base so when I look
at that picture I have to say I don't
feel very soon yeah I feel very excluded
why I don't like the fact that you feel
that way and we need more minorities
more women in our party and I've been
focusing on that kind of recruitment the
person who I'm a mentor to literally
technically that I became a mentor as
Mia love she's somebody I recruited in
the primary to come to Congress there
are a lot of candidates like Mia that
were recruiting all around the country
because I do believe that and that's
something
I'm gonna keep working on that's
something I'm not going away from from
from life I'm gonna keep being involved
in focusing on inclusive aspirational
politics I'm gonna keep fighting for the
things I believe in and that's among the
things I want to do I'm gonna spend a
lot of time with my friend Bob Woodson
on poverty initiatives those are things
I care a great deal about that frankly I
have been not able to spend time on
because of a pretty busy day job you do
have a very busy day job and some people
look at it and say that you know
especially your timing now you know when
some would say you're needed more than
ever as we go as we get ready for the
midterm elections that are you jumping
ship and really leaving the Republican
Party where we need we need the
Republicans hope you say to Gail I love
everybody Paul right you do everybody
loves you because of that but no we're
seriously but uh first of all I'm not
going anywhere anytime soon I'm running
through the tape do you know jumping
ship though no not at all you know why
because I think we have a fantastic
leadership team that we can transition
to easily they already know how to do
the job more importantly I don't think
anybody's particular racing in Congress
is gonna hinge on whether or not Paul
Ryan speaker their house and not it's
gonna be about ideas it's gonna be about
visions it's gonna be about choices but
it sends a message though to some that
you're stepping down at this time well
look you have to make a decision
personally and and and nothing Trump's
my my family nothing Trump's the fact
that I don't want to be a weekend dad
for my entire kids lives and nothing
Trump's the fact that we've accomplished
a great deal who would be a good record
or under gavel well I'll probably make
comments on that a little bit later but
uh we have time now yeah no you run
commercials no because I keep thinking
about the piece that Nora did was with
mr. Scalia and when you walked in there
was clearly a bond between the two of
you that was so genuine and so raw and I
was thinking he must be your leading
candidate can you say yeah or no I'm not
gonna get into those issues up I'll
probably have more to say on that pretty
soon but I love this entire leadership
team I feel very strongly about it we've
gone through a lot together we're very
close and we what I like about this
particular leadership team is we all
rode the boat in the same direction and
that necessarily wasn't the case with
some prior teams let's talk about the
news of the day with mr. Muller
you know there's word there's word that
Steve Bannon is in the president's ear
again and that he's encouraging him to
fire
Robert Muller that he's asked he's
encouraging him not to participate with
the investigation what are your thoughts
about that I obviously don't think he
should do that he knows what I think
about that and I think Bob Miller and
the career professionals of DOJ should
be left to do their jobs
shouldn't Congress take action to
protect it well I don't think that's
necessary because I don't think it's
under consideration then why don't you
think it's under consideration I don't
think it's under consideration
because of the kind of conversations
I've had with people in the White House
I don't think it's in the president's
interest to do that mr. speaker you can
have conversations with people in the
White House and say one thing one day
and then the next day it's totally
different you have whiplash trying to
keep up with what this sure conversation
they are my points are really clear I've
been saying the same thing all along he
should be left to do his job we have a
system based upon the rule of law we
need to respect that system and I think
we should just leave these guys to do
their jobs
what are you proudest of as you get
ready to retire or a bulk of work which
advanced a political philosophy that
brings more growth an opportunity to
focus on the American idea I believe so
passionately this idea in this country
that the condition of your birth does
not and should not determine the outcome
of your life and I think what we've been
able to do to grow the economy makes a
difference I think I've done a lot to
advance the debate on entitlement reform
we have not yet won that debate it's got
to be more bipartisan and I regret that
it isn't but that's how you've prevented
that crisis and I'm also very very and
I've learned spend a lot of time with
the military since being speaker we
needed to rebuild our military we were
people were dying in training accidents
80 last year alone and I'm very proud of
the fact that we have rebuilt our
military our veterans administration and
this economy is growing so I'm just
pleased with that body of work this is
something that's bubbling up this
morning where you said that you're
you're not you're not resigning that you
are retiring but there are some of your
colleagues that are saying bye-bye Paul
Ryan it's time for you to go now let's
get a speaker in there now before the
midterm elections what do you say about
look I don't think the thing there's the
door right over there I don't think most
members want me to do that I serve of
course in this job at the pleasure of
the members but I think that kind of
disruption is probably not
good for us as a party good for us as a
House Republicans okay I think we have a
seamless leadership team that can take
over at the right time all right and one
more thing with teenagers do they want
you home all right yeah believe it or
not they kind of like me no I believe
they like you but I was putting up your
kids again oh good dad's gonna be home
more so they're just as excited you and
Jan I'm sure your wife all right well we
wish you nothing but the best of course
the story's not over we want many more
conversations before January's you thank
you very much for you bet Gail thank you
for coming down thank you